la polémique de la semaine jean gaudet
parti alors j'en voit vite le sujet
parce que ça va vous passionnez chère
maman qui est chez vous notamment les
enfants stars hyper sexualisée voilà
est-ce que ça va trop loin oui ou non
c'est un phénomène qu'on connu d'autres
stars évidemment avant me lie à bobby
brown l'héroïne de la série fringe aux
sims qui est au coeur d'une polémique en
ce moment
regardez le sujet puis derrière on débat
bisous libos biberonne on pense qu'à la
25 ans elle en a tout juste quinze
depuis sa première apparition dans la
série fringe heures 6 en 2016 tout le
monde se lâche
[Musique]
comédienne hors norme elle pose
également comme un mannequin adultes et
commence à inquiéter une gamine à peine
pubères peut-elle être sexualisé à ce
point qu'ils ont effectué ces
inquiétudes de parents flip emilie s'en
fiche
la semaine dernière elle a officialisé
sa liaison avec roméo le fils de
victoria et david beckham est au milite
à 15 ans tu vas te calmes et mili
précoce à dos elle joue à la femme ça
perturbe vous dire pour cette génération
les stars qu'il fascine sont souvent des
artistes quelque peu délurée je pense
que la meilleure rappeuse c'est cardinal
bah oui car dit bill très classieux de
rappeuse le phénomène des ados
scandaleuse commence en 2000 quand
alizés donne sa langue au chat
en 2013 britney fouetter ses copines
avec des mots beaucoup plus qu'à en
janvier dernier la superstar nicki minaj
a fait joliment son autoportrait
[Musique]
et le mois dernier quart diby la
rappeuse préférées 2010 donc nous a
décrit son intimité ocha de quoi
retourner le cerveau de nos ados alors
l'hypersexualisation est-ce que ça va
trop loin
voilà est-ce que ça va trop loin juste
un petit exemple parce qu'elle ne reste
pas beaucoup de temps mais sur natalie
portman c'est quand même incroyable
elle dit qu'elle était tellement
enthousiaste à 13 ans qu'on ait cumulé
on est sorti son travail sa performance
et qu'ensuite y avait ses têtes c'était
tellement incroyable incroyable
puisqu'il radio locale qu'à organiser un
décompte des jours jusqu'à mon 18e
anniversaire d'anna laquelle ça
deviendrait légal de coucher avec moi
mais c'est quand même hallucinant alors
juste à temps justesse que choquer donc
la question est ce que ça va trop loin
il ya eu oui que je veux non non pardon
de mathieu que je voulais entendre non
c'est oui pardon du maître que je vais
entendre
et puis daniel ça va trop loin parce que
c'est uniquement fait pour vendre
quelque chose le produit qu'il ya autour
serre que l'adolescence est apparu dans
les années 60 avant passé d'enfant
adultes tout de suite et maintenant on
fait enfants préadolescents et
adolescents adultes pour vendre les
produits qui sont toujours les vêtements
le maquillage l'attitude chat donc c'est
vraiment le la dérive complète d'un
système marketing ces portables et
surtout ça rend fou parce que vous
pouvez pas avoir une adolescence normale
en blanc par nos électeurs ne va pas
trop loin et pour la simple et bonne
raison que les faits donnent raison
serre que britney spears alizée l'orif à
toutes ces stars qui ont commencé jeune
quand on voit leur vie actuelle elles
sont plutôt rangée sont pas d'élus réels
sont elles sont parfois tu as raison
la voir elle est dans mes lévy polaires
mais sinon elles elles rêvent que d'une
vitesse et se marier avec son mari mais
c'est vrai risque de se marier charisme
elle aurait voulu rester à kevin
federline toute sa vie et celui de ses
enfants franchement c'était son
aspirations les plus profondes réalisé
s'est marié laurie la lgv haussier de
fait l'essai de faire des enfants a
laissé dar el hadith elles ont prêté
aussi 19 exemple d'autres camps
covenants et et des plombs mais alors
oui daniel pour rebondir seulement ni
bovine robots des coups sûrs du
millénaire salle avel c'est non mais la
jeune milly bobby brawn à 15 ans elle a
elle fait les entrées dans une liste des
stars qui rendent la télé plus champ des
plus sexy elle a 15 ans c'était ça
paraît mal à ses yeux la désole
d'orsonnens on est vraiment dans le
sujet de l'hypersexualisation oui mais
il est perverse on voit la fin pour
avoir un peu pardon comme vous on
n'apprécie pas le fréquenter des gens
comme ça en fait ces enfants sont des
victimes
dans le cas de britney spears s'est en
fait c'est les enfants sur leurs parents
c'est leur mère et qui en ont fait ça
ouais c'est les maires qui sont des
artistes frustré etc ont poussé les
petits moyens et hyper sexualisée vous
allez aller concert de laurie vous voyez
des gens des gens qui habille leurs
enfants en mini put pardon excusez moi
fauna parce qu'ils n'ont qu'une envie
c'est que leurs filles deviennent elles
aussi célèbre donc les mères poussent
leurs petits tas est hyper sexualisée
pour devenir des grandes stars les
enfants sont des victimes
c'est les maires qui sont derrière jean
tandis que vous encore des concerts
nouri non non c'est pourquoi pas choqué
parce que je trouve qu'on s'est vus
vachement assagi depuis 20-30 ans moi ce
qui me choque est à la limite c'était
les photos de david hamilton et
d'ailleurs on connaît maintenant les
dérives qu'il ya derrière
donc là c'était quand même plus poussées
man blanche donc ça m'a fait peur parce
que ses fils à celle exemple pour les
jeunes filles à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
ben moi je vois à mon époque moi j'étais
fan d'alizée je me mettais des vêtements
dans mon sac dans mon cartable je me
changeais dans les toilettes du collège
me maquiller et je m'habille et pourquoi
pas je mettais les petits os et tout et
je m'étais fait même attrapé par le
proviseur mam mais ma mère avait été
convoqué lala pourquoi donc en fait et
maintenant c'est normal très bien tu
auras deux grandes et reprend dû revoir
moi je rebondis sur ce que tu dis
session mon agence de communication
réseaux sociaux je reçois des tonnes de
mails de parents qui m'envoient des
photos de leurs gamins
sans cesse d'étonner des tonnes tous les
jours et c'est horrible quoi saviola
mais rien ne sera quoi en faire et le
virage